why
so continuing our discussion with the
civil war issue number two times we pick
up with the New Avengers issue number 21
now this comic is really kind of
interesting and even when I sat down and
read this coming for the first time it
really kind of struck me as strange just
because the artistry was so different
from what I was used to with reading
most of the Marvel comics and that's one
of the interesting things when it comes
to these major crossovers when Marvel
does these huge crossovers they enlist
virtually every single artist that is
working on their current storyline so we
see the artists who are working on New
Avengers we see the artists who are
working on Iron Man we see the artists
that are working on spider-man and they
really all kind of come together to
bring us a full and complete storyline
and so this comic while the artistry is
a little bit strange and is really kind
of weird the storytelling is almost
second to none and what we see is
Captain America really kind of trying to
comment come to peace with himself
really kind of trying to meditate so to
speak as he is painting then really kind
of having this internal debate regarding
his perception of humanity now this is
really kind of interesting because this
is a side of Captain America that we
don't usually get to see in Captain
America for the most part is always
portrayed as being the one guy that
always has faith in humanity that while
humanity will stumble and humanity will
fall and sometimes they will make bad
decisions
he really always kind of has this idea
that humanity will always do what's best
that people are inherently good and they
will always do the right thing and this
comic really kind of gives us this
opportunity to see Captain America
questioning that but while this internal
debate really kind of rages inside of
him he really kind of comes to the
conclusion that this support for the
superhuman Registration Act that this
anger and this backlash that humanity is
showing towards superhumans is simply
result of them being scared really kind
of a result of them being both angry and
scared because of the fact that
superheroes really are not being
regulated by the government and that the
possibility of another Stanford
Connecticut really kind of looms on the
horizon and that it's entirely possible
that someone somewhere could do
something that would bring about another
one of these instances so what we see is
that as cap
America is really kind of meditating
really kind of having this debate with
himself that he is ambushed by shield
agents one of whom is dum-dum Dugan
now dum-dum Dugan is of course the
right-hand man of Nick Fury but is also
a very close friend of Captain America
and Captain America is really kind of
upset to see the shield is resorting to
such underhanded tactics as using a
friend of Captain America's to attempt
to corral him and bring him back to
shield ultimately Captain America is
successful in tricking Maria Hill and
shield into believing that he's been
killed by dum-dum Dugan and escapes the
scene from this point he kind of passes
out and comes to with Falcon in one of
Nick Fury's underground bases now Falcon
didn't necessarily bring him there
Captain America actually traveled there
on his own although at this point he had
kind of blacked out and doesn't recall
that he had got there he's surprised to
see Falcon there and puts him through
kind of a quiz in order for Falcon to
verify that he is who he claims to be
once Captain America is satisfied that a
Falcon is actually who he's supposed to
be the two of them kind of go on this
hunt to build a team to kind of build an
opposing faction to Iron Man and his pro
superhuman Registration Group one of the
first members did they choose to try to
recruit a spider-man but after seeing
him wearing the armor that was given to
him by Tony Stark they really kind of
come to the realization that spider-man
has chosen the side of Iron Man from
here we see Captain America and Falcon
attempt to enlist the aid of Hank Pym
ant-man but we find out very quickly
that ant-man has already chosen the side
of Iron Man and so what we kind of learn
is that Hank Pym has basically kind of
been distracting Sam Wilson and Captain
America really kind of been buying time
in order for shield to have a chance to
arrive we see that ant-man is really
kind of trying to talk Captain America
down telling him that this superhuman
Registration Act is inevitable and they
should side with it ultimately we see
that Captain America and Sam Wilson are
able to swiftly defeat Hank Pym and
escape and go back underground and from
here we will really kind of see this duo
begin to move forward in the direction
of having a sort of recruitment drive in
the sense that they will try to bring as
many people to their side as possible as
we see that the lines are sort of being
drawn
ultimately we will see the team's really
kind of define themselves and of course
on Captain America side we will see
individuals such as cable in addition to
patriot and the Young Avengers as we saw
in the previous Civil War storyline so
as we continue with Wolverine vol 3
issue number 43 we really kind of
continue this trend that we saw in
Wolverine vol 3 issue number 42 where we
have some action but most of the comic
consists of I guess plot developing
dialogue and what we see is Wolverine is
really continuing this quest to locate
and destroy nitro for his actions in
Stamford Connecticut
along the way he is tracked and located
by Tony Stark but because of the senses
that Wolverine possesses his enhanced
sense of smell and so on he is already
aware that Tony Stark is there after a
conversation between him and Tony Stark
where Tony Stark asked will rain to stop
what he's doing because it could lead to
another Stanford Connecticut
Wolverine reveals that he already knows
where nitro is that nitro is in Big Sur
California then Wolverine is really kind
of just blowing off some steam so he
doesn't go into conflict with nitro and
really kind of instigate another
scenario like Stamford Connecticut
in addition Wolverines entire motivation
for this is because if nitro was
captured by shield he'll most likely be
interred you'll be put into a prison
then he'll go through the trial process
and most likely be found guilty for his
crimes and executed but Wolverine feels
like this is a long kind of drawn-out
punishment that it would take ten years
worth of Appeals and so on and so forth
and that Wolverine I'm sorry that nitro
deserves to die now now ultimately we
see that because of the fact that
Wolverine had told Tony Stark that nitro
is in Big Sur California that Tony Stark
invites will ring to join shield as they
attempt to apprehend nitro from here we
switch to Daytona Florida and we see
someone who is a surfer we don't really
know who he is however he is being I
guess maybe looked at by two individuals
who are attempting to locate him and
believe they found him from there we
switched to Wolverines perspective as he
is with multiple shield agents at Big
Sur California attempting to capture
nine
TRO the plan as the shield agents have
laid it laid it out is to more or less
kind of ambush nitro which Wolverine
realizes is kind of a silly plan when
nitro is ambushed by the shield agents
nitro self detonates from there we see
that virtually everybody including
Wolverine appears to be totally
incinerated we also see the nitro
contact someone and takes a couple pills
and these pills are revealed to be more
or less of them mutant power enhancing
pills which allow him to detonate on
such a scale this caused as much damage
as it did in Stamford Connecticut we
ultimately see that whoever it is that
nitro was talking with on the other line
considers nitro to really kind of be a
loose cannon and nitro has become a
threat to him because nitro says that he
has killed Wolverine who is both an
x-man and an Avenger and is really just
kind of drawn way too much attention we
see that ultimately wolverine is
revealed to be alive and his healing
factor has allowed him to restore
himself back to his current form from
here we jump back to the surfer that we
had previously seen and we see that this
individual along with the two people who
were looking for him have extracted
presumably the location of Wolverine and
nitro we ultimately see that this
individual who has named Janus kills the
person that they have extracted the
information from and it's really kind of
stated that this person hates humans so
Fantastic Four issue number 538 largely
follows Ben Grimm the thing of the
Fantastic Four and what's really kind of
interesting about Ben Grimm is that for
the most part for a good chunk of the
civil war storyline Ben Grimm is neutral
he doesn't ally himself with anti
registration or Pro registration he's
just really kind of mulling things over
and trying to figure things out on his
own as the story unfolds we really kind
of begin to see the Johnny Storm is
still unconscious he's still in a coma
following the attack that he received as
an aftermath of the events at Stamford
Connecticut
what we also see is that Ben Grimm is
really the first one taking it in turn
to spend time with Johnny Storm and he
really kind of talks to him really kind
of makes his personal feelings known
really kind of the normal thing that you
would see when a person is spending time
than unconscious individual in addition
we also get a little more elaboration on
the events in Oklahoma and what we see
is that there are a litany of
individuals who are attempting to pick
up the hammer of Thor and the thing Ben
Grimm had informed us that the
government had attempted to stop them at
first but ultimately kind of gave up
just because there were so many people
and there were other matters that needed
their attention in addition we switched
to Ben Grimm after I'm sorry to s Susan
storm relieving Ben Grimm from
monitoring Johnny storm and we see that
Ben Grimm is kind of watching events
unfold on TV as a result of the passing
of the superhuman Registration Act and
individuals on behalf of Tony Stark
really kind of combating and attempting
to apprehend people who have chosen not
to register themselves Ben Grimm travels
to Yancy Street where he watches Miss
Marvel and various other individuals
attending to apprehend superheroes who
refuse to register and Ben Grimm doesn't
really do anything he does really kind
of observes the situation and then goes
to talk to the police
and the police are really kind of
frustrated here because you have
protests or people who are against the
superhuman Registration Act that are
doing the best they can to thwart the
efforts of the police because they
really can't do much to thwart the
efforts of superheroes the police really
kind of want to eliminate the idea of
protesters they really just kind of want
to impose this martial law kind of thing
where protesters are just simply not
allowed to act violently against police
and Ben Grimm really kind of plays the
role of maybe the voice of reason here
stating that just because people are
people object to something just because
they do not advocate what it is that the
police are willing to do it doesn't mean
that the people are wrong they have
every right to really kind of protest
here the best way they know how
from there Ben Grimm really kind of is
frustrated he's really kind of angry on
both sides one he's angry because this
superhuman Registration Act is being
handled for the most part in a very I
guess maybe or Willian way in the sense
that we really kind of see the
government imposing these very stringent
guidelines and really kind of walking
this path it could lead to a very dark
place but we also see the fact that
people are just angry and frustrated and
Ben Grimm's really just kind of
irritated here because he doesn't really
quite know what
to do in addition we see him really kind
of engaging in a conversation with
several street-level thugs in addition
to people from the neighborhood and one
of these members and his name kind of
escapes me here engages in a pretty
in-depth conversation with Ben Grimm and
really kind of talks to him about how
Ben Grimm needs to choose a side how the
government and what they're doing just
isn't right and somebody needs to stand
up for superheroes even if it is
street-level people he talks about how
they really have no powers
there isn't a whole lot that they can do
but they can do something which is
better than doing nothing
ultimately Ben Grimm really kind of
leaves the scene and we also kind of
switch to the thinker who is a longtime
enemy of the Fantastic Four and we
really kind of see him discussing with
puppet master how the events as they're
unfolding we're really kind of lead to
the ability for him to really kind of
step in and to manipulate things for his
own benefit and what this really does is
kind of demonstrate to us along with the
events that we saw and Thunderbolts
issue number 103 that despite everything
that's going on that villains are going
to continue being villains that villains
are going to continue scheming and
they're going to continue manipulating
things for their own ends from here we
jump back to Oklahoma and what we see is
that among all the people who are
attempting to lift the hammer of Thor
one individual in a top hat and a
trenchcoat
walks up with a duffel bag and is
successfully able to take the hammer of
Thor
so Civil War frontline issue number
three really kind of continues this
trend following Sally Floyd and Ben
Urich as they really kind of begin to
ally themselves with their respective
camps now one thing to bear in mind is
that these individuals at this point in
time aren't necessarily fighting on the
side of their respective camps that is
really kind of read I guess representing
them through the media and we see the
Sally Floyd has been taken to a secret
location where she is meeting with
various superheros which include people
like solo and typeface and battle star
who at one point was an ally of Captain
America he was a sidekick and actually
carries an adamantium shield the same
kind of shield that Captain America
carried in his early days and what we
see is that these individuals have
chosen not to register they have really
kind of gone underground
and they are aware that a
anti-registration movement is forming
being led by Captain America but they
don't really know how to get into
contact with it and so by virtue of
allowing an anonymous interview between
Sally Floyd and themselves they're
hoping they can kind of make contact
with this underground group and really
kind of begin to build a stronger
alliance with other superheroes who have
refused to register in addition we see
that individuals such as typeface for
example have opposed registration
because they view this to be a draconian
law and is not really in accord with the
kind of freedoms that have been laid
down for American citizens by the US
Constitution we also see people like
Battlestar who are against registration
because it simply just violates personal
privacy and then people should not be
made to live in a country that is ruled
by government which forces its people to
live in fear we also switch to Ben Urich
and what we see with Ben Urich is that
he is interviewing Reed Richards of the
Fantastic Four and Reed Richards is
really kind of introduced Ben Urich to
this holographic map that he has
designed which is more or less kind of
using a mathematical algorithm to
determine the I guess maybe
ramifications of what would happen if
superheroes were allowed to continue
their actions unchecked and what we see
is this sort of spread like a plague or
an illness where individuals who are
superheroes allow and really kind of
cause more and more damage and more loss
of life as a result of their actions now
Ben Urich doesn't necessarily buy this
but because he is writing an expose on
the pro registration movement he's of
course taking this information but you
can kind of see to a degree that there
is logic in what it is that Reed
Richards is saying now from this point
we switch to a battle between Bantam and
thunderclap and this is a relatively
significant battle but not as
significant as we will see later on what
we see is that this is in fact one of
the very first instances of fatalities
as a result of the combat between those
who are pro registration and those who
were anti registration bantam is a pro
registration individual he is actually
one of the first people to register as
soon as registration was required for
superhumans we see the thunderclap is
anti registration and during their
conflict which is being observed
bye Sally Floyd Bantam is thrown into a
tanker truck by thunderclap which
explodes and kills Bantam now
thunderclap is really kind of guilt
ridden by this and again we really kind
of follow a little bit of a monologue
where Sally Floyd is really kind of
commenting on the statements of
thunderclap that he didn't mean for this
to happen then it wasn't intentional
and she goes as far as to say that when
you're on the battlefield and you're in
a war and you aim down the scope to kill
an enemy that it's nothing personal and
it's really kind of an allegory to the
fact that despite the fact that it's not
a personal thing it doesn't mean that it
doesn't it doesn't hit somebody
personally that doesn't mean that it
doesn't have the same kind of
destruction as it would if it were a
personal thing from here we switched
back to speed ball and speed ball
situation has really kind of gone from
bad to worse
and the reason why is because right now
he has Jennifer Walters representing him
as a defense attorney but Jennifer
Walters has really kind of taken the
same stance that the that Shield has
taken in the sense that she's trying to
help him get out of the situation but
every scenario that she presents to him
where he can sign a document and
essentially be become a free citizen is
kind of tied to him admitting guilt tied
to him admitting that the New Warriors
had screwed up and they had caused the
entire incident in Stamford Connecticut
that led to the death of so many people
ultimately we really kind of see that
the ridicule that speedball has been
facing at the hands of prisoners kind of
comes to a head and he challenges one of
the individuals to kind of a boxing
match to really kind of establish the
fact that he's not willing to put up
with this kind of negativity anymore in
addition we see that the final offer
that he has given on behalf of the
federal government through Jennifer
Walters is that he can admit his guilt
he will be sentenced to three years of
community service which will entail that
he register himself and act and
accordingly and that he will be one of
the superheroes that will round up
various supervillains or those
individuals who refused to register in
the Marvel community speedball initially
agrees he initially says that he will
sign the document but then we see that
he says he will sign it when hell
freezes over from there we switch over
to a story about a guy named Joe and Joe
is the was at one point the owner of a
areum however the aquarium has been
destroyed and we're really kind of
following these two detectives as
they're trying to figure out what's
going on we really kind of do a little
bit of a jump back here so to speak in
the sense that we talked about Joe or we
really kind of see Joe before the
destruction of the aquarium and before
he vanished and we really kind of see
that Joe is an ordinary older man he
really is kind of a guy in his 50s maybe
and he leaves a very simple life he runs
a kind of a pet shop he takes care of
fish and so on and so forth his life is
very basic and as he is as the the pet
shop closes and as he is watching
television with his wife he's watching a
sort of news report about multiple
whales which have beached themselves and
the news reporter plays a clip that they
entertained which was a strange whale
song that was kind of being played 10 to
12 miles out to sea
Joe hears this song and really kind of
goes into a trance where he goes into
his bathroom and injects himself with a
syringe at this point Joe's physical
forms and features begin to change and
is revealed to us that Joe is an
Atlantean a member of the kingdom of
Atlantis and one of the citizens under
the rule of Namor the Submariner